my name is kevin adams and i am a
technical instructor for the united
states army and i'm a part-time
blakesmith my grandfather and my father
worked in the same steel mill together
so their influence enabled me to be able
to pick up the trade fairly quickly
my name is eric fontaine and i have been
bladesmithing now for almost 10 years i
stay with it because it's a comfort
place for me and just being able to
create something it's a really cool
experience well kevin eric
congratulations you guys are both moving
forward into round three of our
competition where we will be sending you
home to work on an iconic weapon from
history and that weapon is
the serrated taga sword
the lord have mercy
originating in india in the 18th century
this intimidating curved sword was known
to be a great executioner
its unique design features a nearly
three foot long blade with a split tip
and serrated edges that could easily be
had a man
its two-prong tip is a powerful symbol
throughout the islamic world and is
inspired by the legendary sword zalfikar
which is believed to be descended from
the prophet muhammad
you guys have a lot of parameters to
follow so pay attention
you guys need to make a blade that is
between 24 and 26 inches
that curve depth needs to be no less
than three and a half inches
you need to have a split at the tip that
goes down between 10 and 11 inches
followed by a puncture hole at the end
of that split
the curved edge and the back edge of the
split need to be serrated and sharpened
now you guys need to have a conda style
hilt with a tailed pommel
i have never seen anything like this in
my life it's got these crazy curves it's
serrated everywhere it just combines so
many different skill sets it's gonna be
a challenge to create
you have four days at your home forges
we'll see you then
good luck good luck to you as well
i'm back in my home forge and i'm ready
to start working on this serrated taga
the length and the curvature of the
blade is something i've never had to
deal with before start getting my blade
forged to shape
looks like a hockey stick
so now i gotta shape the tip
that's concerning for me because the
only thing i have to cut metal with is a
grinder you don't have a lot of control
not pretty but it's a start
getting ready to quench the blade
she's hard the heat treat went good
it's a lot of work to do yet
but it's a good start
today is make that cut from the hole to
the tip this is a butt puckering moment
for me if this doesn't work i'm in deep
trouble oh man that is way too thin up
there
what can you do
now my biggest challenge is like
handling guard there's a lot of moving
parts with it
even though it's a lot of hard work and
there's frustration i had fun that's why
we do this craft
[Music]
it's gonna be back here in my own domain
i'm gonna be building a serrated tega
sword i've never done anything even
remotely close to it so it's gonna be an
exciting build
if i got the rough shape on my tip i'm
going to take it over to the vise and
i'm going to start splitting it down
while my steel's heating i might as well
be doing something else this is gonna be
the guard i grab the metal that i'm
gonna be using for my pommel and the
guard i start forging those into the
proper dimensions right now i feel like
i'm in pretty good shape
time to quench
it's actually not bad
it's time to assemble this thing anyway
that's more better less worse
now that i have a finished plate i have
a piece of roast beef
that is a nice clean cut right there
ladies bits welcome to the keel test
let's find out what kind of lethal
damage you're a serrated tega will do
kevin you're up first you ready where
did those will ever be let's do this as
doug is getting ready to do the kill
test i can feel my heart rate is
increasing is there a flaw in there
anywhere did i heat treat correct so i'm
feeling not that confident
all right kevin let's talk about your
serrated tiger here first up the
serrations you have here are indeed very
sharp you can feel every cut now your
handle construction is smooth a little
bit on the wider side of this handle but
it was an issue in controlling your
weapon overall sir your weapon it will
kill
all right eric ready to
take a look
i'm ready let's do it all right kevin's
blade performed absolutely phenomenal i
mean he cut the dummy's head off i've
gotta perform at least at that level to
even have a chance at winning this thing
all right eric the serrations on your
sword are sharp when i rip through the
shoulder it cut easily
now your sword is much lighter it tapers
before it gets to the bend making the
sword easy to swing one-handed overall
sir your weapon
it will kill awesome
all right gentlemen time for the
strength test now to test the strength
and overall construction of your blades
i will be taking them and smashing these
pots now remember this is not about how
well your blades hold up through this
punishment kevin you're up first you
ready yes sir
kevin
your handle it's kind of fat but your
distance your scale with your guard is
great for me as far as your blade goes i
mean you've taken some pretty big hits
and lost a lot of the tips of your
serrations the blade is in one piece
it's still solid nothing loosened up
well done thank you all right eric ready
to get ugly
tear it up
[Music]
i wasn't expecting sparks
so eric right off up here on your blade
you've taken some damage on these
serrations you've lost a bit of those
edge it's still in one piece you did a
good job congratulations thank you
all right bladesmiths it's time to find
out how sharp your blades are this is
the sharpness test the jackfruit slice
to find out how sharp your weapons are
i'm gonna take your weapon to cut the
rope and release this jackfruit then i'm
gonna slice through it now unlike the
strength test this is all about what the
edge of your blade does to the jackfruit
kevin you're up first you ready yes sir
let's do this
so
all right kevin talk about your edge
here so the sweet spot that we have
right here for this sword took a lot of
damage during the strength test so an
initial cut on the rope didn't cut now
on the second cut we use a little bit
other parts of the blade where it is
sharp it cut the rope and it cut the
jackfruit so overall sir your weapon
you will cut
all right eric your turn so you ready
let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
all right eric so it's the same thing
the sweet spot on this blade took some
dulling on the strength desk and it did
affect cutting the rope in the first
attempt on the second attempt cut that
rope and it also cut the jackfruit in
half overall sir your weapon you will
cut excellent
well gentlemen we gave you an extremely
difficult blade to build in the tega
sword and you both performed
exceptionally well in our tests but the
judges have made the decision and there
can only be one champion and the fortune
fire champion today is
eric congratulations kevin unfortunately
didn't make the cut and dave's gonna
tell you why kevin what this came down
to was the heat treat in that blade not
getting it hard enough and so many of
those teeth just got pounded back into
that blade that's why we're letting you
go oh yeah
well kevin you did exceptionally well
but unfortunately your time in the forge
has ended i'm gonna have to ask you to
please step out
that was probably the most challenging
thing that i've ever done it had about
half a dozen things that i'd never done
before i gave it my all so i'm pleased
with what i've brought to the table and
i'm ready to get back at it again
eric congratulations you are today's
fortune fire champion feel pretty good
i'm feeling amazing you're definitely
impressed good job man without further
ado there is a check for ten thousand
dollars waiting for you out that door go
grab it thank you
i don't even know how it
oh man that is it's a surreal feeling it
still hasn't even kicked in i recently
got engaged so i will be putting the ten
thousand dollars towards my wedding and
my honeymoon afterwards
love you baby
you